Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to "Emily Is Away".
Now, we're starting Chapter 3 in the Winter of 2007.
I may be flirting with both Emily and Evelyn, D:
I may be flirting with both Emily and Evelyn,
but I did get confirmation that
this Emily is completely different
from the original Emily from the other game. (WHAAAT?)
I don't know what it is about girls named Emily (me neither)
I don't know what it is about girls named Emily
but I'm gonna maintain my... delightful- Oh.
JUSTIN TIMBERLAKE?! (NOOOOO)
Oooooo
I'll go "Rise Against".
I'll go rise against.
(quietly) Let's see
Uh- Ooh- Hey.
I'll be right with you, I'm worki- EY-
HOLD ON there
I'm gonna work on this stuff (OK..)
Uhhhh let's see...
Juno! Uhhhh.
Juno!
"Life's too short to wait" (wow, thet's deep)
Life's too short to wait
Let's see
"Designer of my own cata-" (I like this one)
"Designer of my own cata-"
"Life's too short to wait." (Deepiplier)
Alright! What'd you got for me? (nothing)
Alright! What'd you got for me?
"Heyyy"
Heyyy
GREETINGS! (I'm Chara)
GREETINGS!
"YOOOoooOOOoo"
Alright, what's up?
"Eagletwo! Heyyy"
Yo, dawg. What's up. BLAH
Yo dawg wassup
Yo dawg.
WOAHHHH "YO EVEE"
Let's see,
"how are you?"
Ohh..
"PRETty good", you?
Let's see
"What are you up to?"
Ugh you know, "HOMEWORK" (lying)
Tryna LEARN (nope)
"I'm graaand"
"Heyy,you shoud listen to som music with mee!"
*squeaky voice* Are you
You druunnkk? (nooooooo...)
Let's see
"Of course!"
Of COUSE (XD)
Let's see, ahh (there are a lot of "let's sees" in this)
Oh.. I wanna listen! I wanna
be cool like you!
Let's see..
Uh oh..
Ass?! Why does it got ass in it?
Oh God!
I'm getting-
Oh.. Manchester orchestra!
Ohh!
I wish I could've done that!
"Just a warning it's pretty emo."
Hang on, lemme get to both of these.
Hang on- Wait..
Ooo! That's nice!
Okay, thank you for tha- *laughs*
Thank you for that! That was real good
that was really good.
Let's see.
Oh
This is
This is,
"this is really good!"
And what about this one?
Let's see here.
[Music starts playing in background]
Oh!
[Music skips, then stops]
Em- emo indeed! But you know I like it, it's cool
alright.
What do we got here?
"Woah! It's snowing outside! (Cool)
Do you like snow?"
Yeah actually, I-I freaking LOVE snow!
Winter is the BEST!!
Except for fall, you know I like fall.
Let's see..
But it's still gooood!
Why are you listening to it?
"Hah. It sticks around-"
Man jumping between is going to be hard!
"ha, sticks around. my badd
I hope it's stuck aroind" (around)
Let's see..
Let's se- Ahh
"I still understand you!"
I'm a smartie!
"I'm just feeling really down"
Uh oh.
Hmm.
"Is everything okay?"
"Is everything," *laughs* "like, okay?"
"Everything's whatever. Today just really sucked.
You're the first person I'm talking to all day"
Let's see.
Let's se-
"Were you not talking to other people by choice?"
"Good I'm sorry for all my spelling mistakes."
Let's see.. Uhhh
You drunk?
"hey no offense, but are you drunk?"
Just asking..
Just curious..
Let's see.. "Hah! Oh noo! Is it that obvious? I am a liTtLe!"
*laughs*
Let's see..
"Hah! Nice"
"I thought you said you didn't drink!"
Let's see
"Yeah, I was hoping to get better,
but I can tell I'm not fun to talk to right now."
Let's see...
AAAHhhh
I don't care about that.
Oh I don't care about-
Is that "I don't care about that"? Is it like-
I don't care if you're not fun to talk to?
"Oh come on, I don't care about that!"
Yeah, that's-
That's what I meant.
That's what I meant!
"But I do and right now I'm just like stupidly emotional."
Let's see-
I mean- I- I-
"I'm here for you if you need me!"
If you need me, I'm here.
Oh- Hi-
"Things change, I guess!"
"Thanks Mark, I'm just feeling so sad and worthless."
Let's see.
"You're not worthless."
Don't say that.
*quietly* Let's see-
"Because I'm drinkin' tonoiGHT"(Tonight)
Ok
Alright.
Go nuts!
"You'll be fine, go crazy!
Have you been drunk before?"
Let's see.
"Thanks.  I'm just so ready for today to end"
Let's see
Uhhh.
Ohh..
*prrrrbbbb* BLAAH
Start fresh?
"Yeah- just start fresh tomorrow."
Maybe..?
I have no idea if that was the right answer.
"I wonder if I'll get a hangover-"
Oh.
"A few times but never this drunk beferr (before)
I wonder if I'll get a hangover tomorrow"
Let's see
Aaasprin. "Just take a few asprin before you go to bed."
I know all the secrets
Oh boy.
"My brain just won't stop. I'd really appreciate it if it would fuck off"
Let's see
Mmm-"make some tea?"
"You could make some tea?"
This is a bad suggestion, but it's all I got.
"Yeah, that could help. At least talking to you is making me feel better."
Oh
Uh- "keep talking! Is something going on?"
"Thanks for the tiop" (tip)
Let's see
What's the occaaasion?
"Celebrating something I guess"
*offended scoff* Ah! "And you didn't- you didn't invite me?
What're ya celebrating!?"
"Yeah it's still a mess in my head." Oh boy.
"Uhhh just how shit everything is, lol"
Let's see
Uhhh, "Em, what do you mean?"
"I might just need to vent about it"
Let's see
"I'm here for you. If you want to talk." Always.
"Do you actually want to talk about it?"
Let's see
"I'm always here, what's bothering you?"
Ooo boy. *laughs*
"Are you sure Eagle One? It's just a whole bunch of shit"
Let's see
"Tell me about it!"
I'm ready! I'm- *laughs*
I'm ready and open for two conversations at once!
"I'm feeling a little stuck."
Let's see. "How do you mean?"
Hoo boy. *laughs*
"It's just been a shit day. I'm all alone."
Oh!
"I'm here!" Hey, I'm here for ya!
Let's see.
"Just nothing like I do matters you know?"
Ohh.
*softly* ohh...
"I know that feeling."
Oh boy, here we go.
"Thanks Eagle One, I'm sorry I'm such a mess"
Let's see
"Oh come on, you're not a mess!" Oh boy.
"I just don't know how to fix w- what to do to fix it"
Let's see. "Change things up?"
Let's see.
"It's embarrassing. I don't want to be like this.
Like fuck, now I'm starting to cry like an idiot."
Let's see.
"What's going on!? Talk to me!" Tell me details!
"It's just really frustrating." Ohh.
Is it..
Is it *ss*...
"Is it... Jeff?"
Let's see. "I dunno I though this bullshit was over"
uhhhh.. Is this ab- like uh
"This about.." *psh* "Steeeve?"
*laughs* Fuck. "Yeah I think he's like the root of it."
Let's see. "How so?" *panicked* Oh boy! Ho boy.
"Of course you could tell, yeah it is."
Let's see. Uh. "He still back on the wake-ends?" (weekends)
Oh boy. "I want us to change, I just don't know what to do."
Let's see. Talk to him? "You could talk to him?"
"Yeah he does. I see him around all the time"
Let's see.. uhh.... *rushed*
"D'you think he still has feelings?"
Ooh boy! (O_O)
"I've tried, I (unintelligible) of over."
"Something happen?"
Ho boy. Let's see...
I dont-I don't know
"I don't care lol"
"Something happen?"
Okay, Let's see..
*rushing*"I mean, nothing in particular, I've felt this way for a while"
Let's see...
ooohhh
"That's a really tough situation!"
*Panicked voice* "I'm very much over him"
Let's see...
"Good for you! you deserve way better"
Ooohhh... "bring it up last night"
"Was he back from college?"
Oh boy!
Let's see. Uhhhhhhh...
"I think he's even more of an asshole now"
Agh
Huh
Let's see.
ppphft --oh my god
Oooh man, oh fuck
I got it wrong, yeah...
I fucked up.
Uuggghh
I misspoke. "Oh yeah I misspoke, I meant like he was home"
Oh fuck.
"Thanks he's even moh-" Oh fuck I fucked that one up.
Jesus.
*sigh*
Let's see...
Uhh, "He's changed in college?"
Oh fuck.
Oooh, I've really fucked that up.
Ahh my hands!
MY HANDS!
"I guess so, fuck him"
Ohh.
"Has he changed since going to college?"
Uhh... "I guess so- fuck him."
Let's see.
"Did something happen?"
Oh boy.
Oof.
"You seem distracted, we don't have to talk.
Let's see.
"No, I want to talk!"
*laugh* I am frantically typing.
"Kind of, I haven't told any one about it yet"
Let's see.
"I'm here for you, you can talk to me"
"okay, you just have to keep this stuff secret okay?"
Let's see
"You can trust me, Em."
"you have to promise not to tell anyone"
Let's see
"Cross my heart and hope to die"
*nervous chuckling*
Okay, here we go
Here we go again.
Fuck!
Let's see
"Truth is I've wanted to break up with Jeff for a while"
"Well something really stupid happened last night."
Okay, "And surprise, Steve's part of it"
"Stupid? What happened?"
"I tried last night but he just refused."
Well.. "What do you mean?"
"Jackie was throwing a party so I was there hanging out"
Let's see, "I'll start from the beginning" Okay.
"And of course he showed up because he's back"
Let's see
Ohh. "Did you talk to him?"
*rushed* "I think I remembered he was working in November."
Let's see... let's see.
Uhh... "Did something specific happen?"
"Yeah he was being different, but *mumbles* really talk to each other..."
"Not really it was more of a bunch of little things"
Uhhhh
Let's see
You didn't- buh - why didn't-
"Why didn't you tell him then?"
"Last night he came over the second he got here"
Uhh...
Let's see.
"Came onto me..."
"but there was just never a good time."
Let's see...
"There's no such thing as good time for that"
Let's see, uhhhh
"How it's going on, how he got a new girlfriend"
"He's got a new girlfriend?"
"I know it felt like there was too much going on."
"Plus, I don't know, I thought my feelings might change."
Let's see
"Soo.. you just.. stuck it out with him?"
Let's see, "but he just started talking about the year."
Ohhh
"What about your breakup?"
Oh boy
"Yeah and some stuff was nice.
but I was still happy." Let's see-
Ooh, "I"m so sorry."
Emojis always make it better.
"Basically a whole bunch of bullshit"
Let's see..
"Did it make you happy?" Lets see...
"Yesterday I asked him hanging out..." Let's see.
Uhh.. "What did he say back?"
"Kind of, it was hard to tell if he was sincere."
*panic* Oh boy!
This is so hard.
"Initially he was busy later but eventually said yes"
"Like I've gotten over Steve"
"We agreed to meet at his house"
Let's see, uhhh
"Why meet at his house?"
"It was nice to talk about everything"
"Did you get some closure?"
Let's see- "So he felt better, I don't know?"
*sigh* "Kind of, people kept interrupting"
"and when we got there he just started crying."
Lets see..... *exasperated sigh*
"Did you stand your ground and still talk?"
"We ended up ditching-a-going outside" Lets see-
"WHy did you ditch the party?"
"Ya, we still talked about everything" -Whoo Boy!
ahh... "just somewhere we could be-eh- and then I made up my mind and told him
I wanted to break up with him."
Let's see. What did, Jeeefff say back. Oh boy
"It was really nice of him"
"Yeah closure can be great"
Oh boy.  "He was quiet for a bit"
(Stressed noise)
"Then he shouted no"
"He just said no?"
Let's see..
"What the fuck Steve?"
Oh boy
"Yeah shouted it. He was like angry"
Hahh..
"I know the fuck St.." -right
(inaudible) "couldn't throw away.."
"How did you react?"
Uhh grabbed me. Let's see
"Did you punch him?"
Let's see "I didn't know what to do"
"Please tell me you punched him."
Let's see
"You bet I did" Uh
"What an idiot." Let's see
"Was Jeff yelling back?"
Hoh boy
"Started shouting back saying I was toying with him"
oh fuck
"Then he fucked off"
"Did you go back too?
Let's see
"Yeah turned into real con.."
"Eventually just left"
"And you just went home?"
"No I ended up just walking home"
Oh fuck
"And that's not even the worst of it"
uuhh don't know- "What happened?"
"yeah I didn't know what else to- so just wake up this morning" Let's see..
"What did Jeff say?"
Let's see. Hoh he's Jeff
"For him-eh Steve went back to the party and told everyone about us"
See. Uh he said "I tried to kiss him"
"What the fuck Steve?"
"See I like it or not."
"Think he's serious?" oh boy
See I know that (inaudible noises)
"So yeah (inaudible)"
OH NO, NO NOT THAT ONE
OH MY GOD
"Bunch of idiots" Oooo what a bunch of idiots
That's not what I meant.
"What the fuck?"
Of course I am sorry I just couldn't say the thing
(Markiplier is stressed)
Let's see
"Why weren't you responding?"
"Just thinking about what to say."
"All my friends.."
Not your friend then
Phew
Uhh "Sounds like they're not you're friends then"
"Well I'm gonna go."
God damnit!
Let's see.
"I'm here now Em."
"I just feel like such an idiot I should have seen it coming."
See..
"You know who he is now."
"Don't call me that."
"You know I guess I was wrong about us, just like you."
Awh man. See..
"You weren't wrong about us." Oh boy
Ahh ok
That is set up for failure.
That is straight up set up for failure.
It is like- that particular one.
There's, human reaction times are not
fast enough for that.
Fuck.
"Lost my friends."
Let's see.
"Real friends will stay."
"I'm sorry for being so weak."
Let's see.
"Honestly I'm really glad you came to me and we can talk about it."
Phew
"Thanks a lot for letting me vent."
"What do you think about the whole situation?"
Let's see.
"Steve's an asshole, plain and simple."
Phwouh mambajamba.
Hoh. "What should I do about him?"
Let's see. Well..
"Tell his girlfriend." Yeah
Just tell his girlfriend that's probably a good idea.
He tried to kiss ya
Ow my hand is cramping so bad.
Let's see.
"She deserves to know. The kinda scumbag she's dating."
Oh man, my hand is cramping soo bad.
Fuck.
Oh my god.
Hah.
"What should I do about my friends?"
Let's see.
"Tell them the truth. About what happened."
I mean if they're real friends they'll either..
Go with it y'know they'll.. they'll believe you or y'know
Let's see.
"Your true friends will"
That's the one I was trying to say.
Ahh.
AAH.
"Okay I'll tell them the truth too."
"Thanks for helping me with all this Mark."
Oh my god.
Fuck.
Uhh
"Anytime Evee, I'm always here for you!"
Fuck. It really hurts.
Like I'm not even joking this fucking hurts.
I cramped up my, my pinky really bad.
"You give pretty good advice."
Let's see. Uhh
"I'm really glad you were able to talk too."
Phew.
"You don't have to lie."
"I was an emotional wreck."
Let's see.
Let's see
"Oh come on no you weren't."
Ugh.
"Seriously though, tonight was really nice of you."
You- "I know you'd do the same for me."
(Quiet) Fuck
Ow.
"Just like don't go anywhere okay?"
(Imma go to bed someone else pick up on Captions?)
(Quietly) Lets see. (I gottchu dude)
"Where would I go?"
Ah
"You're such a genuine person-" that I am.
That I am.
ah not- so glad that the needy
two second response time
Emily over there is- your not as judgmental as Em
Fuck its not often that you find someone like that you know
Lets see
Lets see uh that's you too you know that's you that's you too
( Silence )
I guess its no secret that you mean alot to me
( More Silence )
Like I don't really know what to call us
Lets see yeah I feel we're not just friends?
Yeah i was thinking that too!
I'm glad you feel the same way
loool im glad too
I don't want to like lable us or whatever
But I don't know I really like you
Lets see ( how many times did mark say Lets see XD )
I like you too Iike you too I don't know if i would call you my favorite just yet
"I just hope we're always this close."
"Or even closer!"
*Demonic Laughter*
Sorry, Sorry about that
That was not necessary..
"Maybe we can hang out tomorrow"
" I'd be so nice to not think about this drama"
"Sounds great!"
Can you bring an ice pack for my wrist?
I think I instantaneously got Carpal Tunnel from that.
"Idk maybe hang out and just listen to music or something?"
"You can bring you favorite alternative cds over"
Lets see
"Yeah, that'd be a ton of fun"
That'd be a ton of fun
"Awesomesaucee"
Hell yeah
"Oh man, are you tired"
Lets see
"Not at all! Are you?"
"Oh yeah! I think I might call it a night"
"I'll definately see you tomorrow..."
Whether you like it or NOT.
I will be there ALWAYS!!!
You will!
*In a super creepy voice*
YoU wIlL!
That also sounds like a threat
"G'night eeagleone!!"
G'nigght evee!
G'NIGHTT
THUMP
Uhh..fuck..
Yeah.. SO I don't know how you could possibly.. POSSIBLY! Keep up with Eve's..
With *Emily's conversation there.
Because Emily was flying WAY faster than Eve was flying
Or maybe that was just me from what I saw
BUT it seemed like-like-like it just seemed like Emily's conversation was going WAY faster and WAY WAY needier
Like and I'm not saying "Oh ShE wAs NeEdY" but she was a *little* needy and it was just like FUCK I didn't respond in two seconds!
Come on! I'm only human here!
Even if I was just talking to you THAT would be hard
HUHH.. But we're moving on!
Moving on!
Fuck how could anybody do that
or maybe it set up you either jumble the conversation with Evee or Emily
depending which one your focused on more
But frankly like I did good on both. I don't know if anyone would ever be able to do both
Fuck okay
Ahhhhhhhh
T-pain
Linkin Park
Let's see
Ahhh hot fuzz of course yea
*Sings* We- we all have scars
I've got scars. I've got lots of scars
Hey best fraaen. Yo youuuu
Yo youu Evee! *Chuckles at him self* Fuckin what up
I know we already chilled today but I miss yea
Let's see
Ahhhhhh hang out tonight?
I wish! I have so much homework due tomorrow
Oh! Ojvk
So what are you up to?
Oh, y'know
Ugh just homework too
I just asked you what you were
I already know what you're doing
What's with these people here?
Fucking Kellbells
Let's see
What's the project
Uh, we have to write a poem
Is there a prompt for it?
Yeah, but it's super vauge, what should I write about?
You should write about me obviously
so fucking interesting
I'm like the best
I think I can do that, I really like this class
Hopefully an easy A too, anyone I know in it?
I don't think so, I didn't know anyone
Is Emily in there?
but some of the people in it are pretty cool
Let's see
I'm jealous. That sounds awesome
*mumbling*
"oh yo! guess what?"
hehe, no chicken butt (?)
whaaaaaaat~
"ive been trying to get into alternative because its your favorite"
"and i found a song that's halfway there!"
oh
send it to meeeee!
aww that's so mice, shared interest
im ready!
let's see
here we go. OOh~
That's good stuff
Nice! That's good stuff!
That's good stuff Em. Let's see
I like it a lot! I actually like this a lot.
Dats good stuff
Dats good stuff!
Duck yeah! Isn't swell?
Oh man jack is blowing up
muy phone right now
Let's see. Uh OH what's going on?
Oh nothng crazy, she's trying to plan a big party
Ooo
When s this party?
Same night as prom
It's an antiprom party
So speaking of prom...
*evil laughter*
Uh yes?
Whadaa you wana doo? Wanna skip it together? F*ck prom! I didn't go to prom!
I didn't go to prom at all!
Waanna skip prom and hang out together?
"skip it together like, as in a date?" Let's see.
Yeah, if that's cool with you!
Fa- I didn't go to prom! Who needs to go to prom?